the question is did they accused for see
the possibility of the resultant death
yet persisted in his deed and reckless
whether death insured or not in the
circumstances of this case the answer
has to be no how could the accused
reasonably have foreseen that the shot
he fired would kill the disease clearly
he did not subjectively for see this as
a puzzle as a possibility that he would
kill the person behind the door let
alone the deceased as he thought she was
in the bedroom at the time to find
otherwise would be tantamount to saying
that they accused the reaction after he
realized that he had shot the deceased
was faked that he was play-acting merely
to delude their own lucas at the time
dr. stick an independent witness who was
at the accused house minutes after the
incident had occurred stated that the
accused looked genuinely distraught as
he prayed to God and as he pleaded with
him to help save the disease there was
nothing to Gein say that observation and
this Court has not been given any reason
to reject it and we accepted as true and
reliable it follows that they accuse
iran us belief that his life was in
danger excludes dolis the accused
therefore cannot be found guilty of
murder dolus evangelist